so before meeting a lot of nerdfighters
last night in single n double and single
T Cincinnati I was here in the Miami
whitewater forest where the autumn
leaves are falling and the squirrels are
appropriately afraid of humans and while
walking alone through the forest I
thought to myself I don't really want to
make a thoughts from places video today
while I'm here I just want to go on a
freaking walk without videotaping every
single thing I do
so it's question Tuesday the day that I
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters let's get right to it what
are you gonna be for Halloween I'm gonna
be a 35 year old man why is legislation
to kill the penny being held up in
Congress because if the current Congress
were actually and physically on fire
they couldn't pass a throw water on
Congress act who is your OTP
peanut butter and honey there Oh TP name
is P bunny what does the Raven symbolize
in that Edgar Allen Poe poem death a
good rule of thumb is that if you see
something that looks like it might be a
symbol in a work by Edgar Allan Poe its
death what's something you've always
wanted to microwave oh peeps
hot plate disgusting somewhat burnt
microwaved peeps to go with my lunch of
apples pancakes for pancakes pancakes I
mean I realize this is stating the
obvious but they are cakes that you can
cook in a pan it's an everyday miracle
would you rearrange the alphabet if you
could
yeah totally I'd be so much better at
alphabetizing if instead of having to
sing the ABC song
every freaking time I could just say big
fjords VEX quick waltz nymph sure we'd
then have two A's but we need two A's
best book I've never heard of the blood
of the lamb by Peter DeVries which
inspired large parts of an imperial
affliction by Peter Van Houten can you
draw a platypus yes yes I can with that
boxset thing coming out that box that
thing comes out on October 25th and
there's a limited edition that have both
The Fault in Our Stars and Looking for
Alaska sign link in the doobly-doo
the juror feels slightly attracted to
Augustus waters while writing The Fault
in Our Stars know a little bit why does
the number pi never end I don't know
it's totally irrational velociraptor or
brontosaurus I don't know let's call an
expert hey Henry do you like
brontosaurus or velociraptor better
you like velociraptors better
velociraptors in what situation is it
appropriate to use the acronym Yolo
really in any situation where you're
acting out of an abundance of caution
for instance I think I'll obey the speed
limit today Yolo or I'm gonna pass up
this opportunity to go skydiving because
Yolo do you think you jump from space no
I wouldn't jump from table favorite
statue this guy least favorite statue
this guy favorite President James K Polk
Napoleon of the stumped if iraq obama
stumbled really post hanks voting video
no wait
really really Hank you are on the
president's tumblr also the president
has a tumblr why don't any of the main
characters in your books have siblings
ah it's just my little way of telling
Hank that he doesn't exist in my
narrative imagination wait who the eff
is Hank Hank is an American folk rock
band originally formed in claremont
california hey what's your favorite part
of Atlas Shrugged no what have you learn
from teaching world history for a year
I've learned that humans generally get
less miserable when we collaborate and
that we get totally hosed when we choose
ideology over actual humans hey when
will your next book come out I don't
know 2014 2015 it's gonna be a while
Gandalf or Dumbledore I'm hiding under
the table so you people can't attack me
but Gandalf
favorite period of history wait for it
the mongols all-time 5 favourite john
green's alright in order ball john green
other john green the political science
professor the mustachioed cavalry
officer and the bigfoot researcher known
as one of the Four Horsemen of Sasquatch
re will this be the last question indeed
it will nerdfighters thank you for all
your great questions Hank thank you for
your brilliant video last week I will
see you on Friday